[Music]
there is a drink in mine now prove it I
just pour it on the table right no how
are you are you guys doing
this episode is brought to you by us
just us just us just us just us and
we're here and kind of in the same
situation as last week I guess a little
further on still at home yeah I like
many of you and we're doing our best to
get a routine and keep it together and
keep positive and all the above yeah
that being said that being said we've
done games in the past on our podcast
where it's super fight and like the
election ones that we did where we have
people in one cup and their superpowers
in another cup roulette of sorts o
roulette of sorts so we're gonna do that
today
it was Gina's idea which i think is a
really good thing well it's like let's
find the hero we need right now and
they're all make-believe
none of them are realistic they're all
for fun I like that and for fantasy the
hero we need just to relax and have a
laugh that's all this is we're not
actually considering these people to be
the heroes I mean they can be but yeah
it's all fiction we're just having fun
so we have in one cup people people with
a few modifiers involved with those
people and then in the other Cup we have
their powers or weapons or abilities or
lack thereof yeah
or condition and they can save the world
and they can save the world they can be
the hero that we all need or not mean at
all and so basically the way it works is
we're each gonna draw one from both cups
and then they go head-to-head and the
winner goes in the winner pile of the
loser get him out of here get him up out
of you and then all the winners are
gonna basically face off with each other
until we are left with one hero we need
that's it
that's what we're doing let's get it
poppin let's get it poppin we came up
with these we came up with these earlier
so we've we've we wrote all these cards
but we never like paired them up yet so
okay
what do you got Home Depot as a person
who knows what's an area 51 but will
only tell you if you tickle them oh damn
okay got some secrets dude quite a hero
all right they're going up directly
against Bob Harper but he can only move
in specific movements that are in
today's WOD that says workout of the day
right that's a cross so he's only doing
like across the burpees or like hip up
camp ups he can only move in those and
his weapon is has that Von Dutch plug
all right so I don't know man so are we
fighting for our own or we just
logically discussing I don't know I
think I think we should logically think
about this okay all the clothes go off
the shelves and we need protection from
the Sun okay Bob Harper has that Von
Dutch plug and he's doing a Kip up and
saying I got that fun yes does Von Dutch
at this point make anything other than
trucker hats yeah they usually go jeans
and I don't know if they make jeans
their social media presence is very bad
so I don't really know what they make
okay but we can assume that they have
like a
t-shirt line and a hat line and Bob
Harper's got that plug he's got that
plug we're on the other hand Home Depot
has a guy or gal or non-binary Joe has a
lot of supplies though so and knowledge
Home Depot as a person does that mean
they are literally carrying all the
tools that come at Home Depot or they
just like all the tools and all it's the
vibe and the energy of Home Depot in one
person no no it's all the tools and
knowledge in one person okay that's no
whoo that's no brainer we need Home
Depot as a person and they know what's
inside area 51 all we have to do is take
a look
careful though careful careful tickling
him he has all these very power scary
pair of tools yeah yeah power scary
power tools how are scary power tool you
do have to be careful when you jiggle
he's got like a table saw don't tickle
him like flippantly okay okay but I
think we should go with Home Depot as a
guy yeah I'm with you
okay Bob Harper bye Bob Harper have fun
doing the rest of your wad I did fold
them just open
yeah it's wrong I folded them open how
do you go first all right
I have Angelina Jolie but won't shut up
about staying hydrated and her
superpower is wears diapers but the
diapers provide GPS location oh [ __ ]
that's interesting yeah go ahead
the entire cast their Jersey Shore and a
hot tub that moves and they're riding a
John Deere try ting these I was
literally like Julianne this doesn't
make any sense like what if we get the
entire cast of Jersey Shore in a hot tub
riding a John Deere tractor backwards so
there but it's on top of a tractor
second week backwards I can do gaming
new gamers how do we not choose them
okay yeah I mean I was gonna say the
only pro to Angelina Jolie that won't
shut up about staying hydrated but wears
diapers but the diapie
diapers give GPS locations that we can
know where she is so we can stay away
from her
she's just like wait so GPS location
does that mean like she has a GPS map of
the world or that she is on GPS maps we
can just see where she is okay then get
her out of here we need the entire cast
of Jersey Shore and a hot tub that moves
so that's on top of a John Deere going
backwards doing gainers but like what
can they do to help us endless things
like well you'd have to be in the hot
tub to hear what they're talking about
oh there's a lot of ideas being
discussed just arguing about the note
yeah Ron stop yeah does it include
Angelina and uh Sammy Angelina
yes Tammy sweetheart no she is no longer
part of Jersey Shore hello this is
current Wow
so Sammy allowed to know she's not part
of this I nothing against her but this
is the caste majority sure she's not the
casa de retour am i wrong what about
like they're all their friends no it's
just the cast okay
it's the cat's aliens else ah no in
there too no she's the producer okay
what the hell I'm just I'm just
clarifying who's in the hot air I'll
just list the names
okay Mike Ron Jenni Angelina Snooki
Pauly Vinny is that everyone JWoww I
already said that Jenni that's it right
okay yeah just the core in Mike's out of
jail and he's season ha he is currently
out of jail just yeah it's the current
all of them right now uh-huh
what about Lauren's Oh Lawrence can come
and then also I am Jelena Dina Dina Dina
Dina Dina what about all their
significant others and kids no kids
okay okay they have to stay wait so
they're gonna miss their kids I don't
care I don't give a [ __ ] Oh kids keep
them care it's not safe for kids to do
gamers exactly okay and the cast of
Jersey Shore just like when they went on
she saw they sign a release
same here okay so if any of them suffer
injuries from the hot tub that does
flips they've you know they've signed
their life it's on TV so I think they
win yeah they definitely win okay I'm
picking another one either
both of mine applause yeah GG's whoa oh
sorry okay you go first
all right speed am in spider-man's
caffeine addicted cousin and the
superpower is one loud fus-ro-dah
this is an Elvis girls joke Julian let
me explain what if we throw dollars well
might be better if I show you a video
it's basically a shout they go
fus-ro-dah like that and it's a shout
and so what does that go damage you know
okay FUS ROH I'll help you okay
FUS ROH please help me aah let me show
you this is a fus-ro-dah
okay so it has like it's like it has
energy with it yeah a shout that like
can hurt someone yeah it's a shout okay
so speedermen who has a fus ro dah who
can do the Fu's ro dah I heard it I got
it
but now I want to watch fus-ro-dah
videos on YouTube we're in the middle
podcast are we because this guy is
shouting a giant off of them don't we
get the cast of Jersey Shore in the
moving hot tub to SiC on you unrelenting
support
okay can I read mine maybe hold on all
right yeah okay my pick is Kristen Wiig
singing only her part and imagine a
friend can time travel but only to take
boobs okay
that person is useless absolutely
[ __ ] useless and knowing because not
only is she just relentlessly seeing
that her part in that stupid video but
but she's just gonna like disappear from
time to time to take a poop in the past
and then come back we're like where the
[ __ ] is Kristen Wiig and then she
appears singing the song and she's like
yeah I just took a poop
say that she's only singing her part she
can't communicate at all
that's so useless mm-hmm so speedom and
spider-mans addicted caffeine cousin who
can do fus-ro-dah
on only one they got one shot what one
loud food truck oh it always says one
still that's like a superhero that's a
superhero yes he's all hopped up on
caffeine we are as we know because we
are hopped up on caffeine all the time
that is a good thing
caffeine it's good for you okay
okay I'll go first oh I got to Oh
Nicolas Cage in an actual cage who
commands an army of rats with small
football helmets on yeah let me tell you
that is a dangerous man right there
there's an argument to be made for that
all right I have every beauty youtuber
but they're linked together by they're
just include Cartier bracelet which is
the ones that shaped like a nail right
but they're okay so they're all linked
together by their nail bracelets okay
and they have a magic carpet but it
smells so bad
okay so not only is that like the first
card alone just super useless because
what the hell is that going to help with
they would just be complaining the whole
time that they're stuck to each other
that they want to get their bracelet
back well they can't take any pictures
of themselves because they're all
chained together or chained together by
their cardio bracelets and they stink
they have to work no they don't stink
they're magic card well they're on it
yeah
so they stink they could probably get
off of it but they have to all work
together they couldn't all work together
well they have to well they can't and
they're gonna just fight over and over
no meanwhile an army of rats with
football helmets on or listening knew
exactly every order that Nic Cage in a
cage gives he's indicated she lives the
rat life okay so he knows how a rat
thinks because he is a rat
mmm-hmm that since when is he now he is
now a rat though he's a rat like you
know he's a rat I don't understand so to
give you like yeah he's just a rat he
behaves like a rat he is the essence of
a rat he crawls around and looks for
cheese and treats and steals [ __ ] like a
rat well five eight one five eight he's
a [ __ ] boy crawling around the walls
looking for cheese that's that's his
essence I don't mean he's he's the form
of a rat
he is Nic Cage he is a guy the right
well he's not the Rat King cuz he is a
rat so the Rat King is like above rats
Nic Cage is he embodies the spirit of
rats
okay yours wins okay because these
people are not gonna get anything done
arguing anything done on a magic carpet
no we're not getting anything done
they're probably not even be able to get
their sponsored posts up for the day
what yo chill sorry well they won't
because they have no Julian sorry you go
first
okay I'll go first
Adam stant Adam Sandler stuck in
character from the cobbler no somos de
LASIK eye surgery
he's a cobbler but he's also enough
optic optician optician ophthalmologist
no that's not an optician opt attrition
optic Jason attrition Trisha no optic
Trisha Jason octa true eye guy I got it
okay
Thor but he's out of movie shape he has
a lot of khaleesies dragons but listen
[Laughter]
first of all out of movie shape can mean
a lot of things he might he might be a
real problem
he's bulking butt out of movie shape
doesn't mean bulk a mean he could be he
doesn't know if there's a sequel oh okay
you know so he's just I don't know okay
not like a Thor in movie shape would
have any better of a time controlling
dragon
I won't listen to him yeah I mean that's
see the movie shape thing is kind of
irrelevant just how they would look but
what do you have again Adam Sandler okay
so think about this of all the medical
procedures that we could use in like a
disaster situation LASIK eye surgery
feels like the least helpful one hmm
because whoo I mean I guess you can make
the argument that people are like they
don't have their contacts and they ran
out or they glasses broke and they can't
see but like really where does he do it
in the dirt on the ground well he's in
character from the cobbler so I imagine
you have to go into his shoe store so
you walk in he pulls out a shoehorn and
he just points it at you and it lasers
your eyes is that what a cobbler does
today of shoehorns I had a lot of
cobbler that's annoying
the thing that you stick on the heel and
put your foot in Oh
do you know I'm talking about I think so
it's like a slide for your heel mm-hmm
your heels like whee and then it's in
the shoe hmm I don't know maybe it would
be helpful to have a guy who knows how
to do LASIK but then again that movie
was bad how is the dragon gonna help us
if he can't control he could defeat the
enemies or he could defeat us or he
could defeat himself he could feed Thor
we gotta pick a winner
I don't know how do I mean I think
having a dragon that one was new is
potentially catastrophic mm-hmm like we
could all just get dot like get deaded
burned get burned so let's not go with
the dress Oh Adam Sandler stuck in
character from the cobbler that knows
how to do LASIK eye surgery yeah because
you know what there's probably gonna be
one of us who needs LASIK maybe not
maybe it's just the skill that he won't
ever help to use at the very least he
can make shoes okay I don't want his
shoes okay
that was a great movie babe no wasn't
you doughnuts hundred-percent a rotten
tomatos tony hawk
but he's an actual hawk at night who are
ironically dresses as Colonel Sanchez
okay when he turns into a hawk is he
dressed as Kurtis Hinda hawk it depends
if he's decided to dress this Colonel
Sanders at night then yes because he's a
hawk at night okay so he's a hawk flying
around advertising fried chicken with
white and red stripes on not sure how
they can help anybody think about this
though okay okay
remember how Bob Harper had that Von
Dutch plug mm-hmm
Tony Hawk probably has that KFC plug
okay just saying something to think
about probably does okay
the intense vocals only of Celine Dion
in her native language which is French
she has great French albums you fake
finns and me the vocals superpower is
can heal people but they have to pee on
them like a jellyfish sting
so Celine Dion running around singing in
French no no while peeing on people not
Celine Dion her intense vocals although
it's not a person it's just for vocals
when you look at her or it what do you
see
pee urine yes floating urine I guess
just pee just like an amoeba of floating
urine hmm and so how does it urine work
it can heal you of what anything I don't
know well what does the card say does it
say he'll you can heal people I love
Tony Hawk especially when he act when he
turns into a hawk at night but I feel
like having someone who could heal you
is hugely helpful well we don't know if
it he'll see you just look if you pee on
a jellyfish sting I think it makes it
feel better but I don't think it heals
you it says heals so if I break my arm
and Celine Dion's voice pees on me I
feel better and I don't have a broken
arm anymore I just realized how out of
takes that whole sentence just sounded
but true right well I don't know does it
heal a broken arm or does it okay when a
jellyfish stings you uh-huh and someone
pees on it yeah how healed is that sting
I don't know I know you're a doctor you
have to answer no I'm not at all it
heals it it says can heal so like not so
she's like a healer but just like
doesn't really want to sometimes yeah
but like has a bunch of DPS skills
slotted and like sometimes yeah yeah
losing me here yeah so I'm gonna go with
Celine Dion this vocals and can heal you
but they have to pee on you like a jelly
as long as we don't have like a pee
fetish person here you know it's not a
pee fetish no okay so it's only for help
yeah it's for help okay
good stuff okay I'll go first
Dog the Bounty Hunter and he's all out
of bounties with toilet paper guns for
hands oh damn okay that is a commodity
right okay Guy Fieri and his teenage son
who keeps saying dad's stock speaks in
wingdings there's nothing does that he
sing his son is saying dad stop but Guy
Fieri can only speak in wing-dings so
question is Guy Fieri speaking in only
wingdings worse than Guy Fieri speaking
how he normally speaks because I think
an argument could be made that it's
better
oh okay right ma'am think of all the
things that might annoy you about him
talking normally yeah and then erase all
of those things because you can't
understand them because he's talking and
wing-dings
even his laughter would be in wingdings
the sound of him licking his fingers is
in wingding to be honest everything he
does I hate and if there's a way to
improve it even to make it
unintelligible I vote for that but is
that helping anyone
literally
okay toilet paper guns for hands though
that's great Dog the Bounty Hunter I
think we go with dogged about and
exquisite leash mullet and a heart of
gold with toilet paper hands do it to
him
I don't know who that is Dog the Bounty
Hunter yeah you never watch that show oh
we're gonna have to watch some okay okay
all right by a guy fieri by Guy Fieri's
son she had a lovely wife named Beth who
sadly passed but she's still in all
those episodes they're great I think I
mean I haven't googled him lately so if
he's problematic I apologize but yeah I
liked this dog the bounty hunters are
real it's like a real show or is it
fiction oh and they like hunt down
people who have bounced you skip court
and then there's a bounty out for your
arrest that's what he does for a living
he got his name's dog yeah look that's
fine
you read okay mr. bean but he can speak
mm-hmm
has coffee breath so strong you smell it
on TV and and he can fly and he can fly
is that on there yeah an actual doctor
who has a handful of Girl Scout cookies
oh okay see here's the problem okay
because now we have a doctor look at
someone who can heal you who can perform
surgery unless they're not a surgeon but
they're a surgeon maybe they're not now
they are who can give you medicine maybe
they're podiatrists but they can't do
any of this cuz they got a handful of
[ __ ] Girl Scout cookies oh so it's
limiting their capabilities well yeah
because Howard like how if you're
getting a shot and the doctor comes out
of the other room and he's just like and
he has Girl Scout cookies like you're
not gonna let him give you a shot like
that well cuz he'd have to do it with
his mouth or his feet I don't know that
one seems really useless mr. bean who
just really like has bad breath and can
fly with it what is he talking about
he's still a doctor like even if he
can't help you he can instruct someone
else how to help you
another thing Girl Scout cookies and a
handful of Girl Scout cookies
yeah that means he has like an unlimited
supply
cookies yes so we can all eat from it
yeah like birds out of his hand okay
we're gonna eat out of his hand
okay that's a good one does the last one
is it yep no there's one more in here
oh okay do we measure wrong I guess so
okay okay Brittany broski on skis who
won't stop dropping their hydro flask on
the ground oh no girl oh no quit
dropping your hydro flask on the ground
no that is not helpful it's very loud
because in addition to the loud bang the
hydro fast makes she's walking indoors
around on skis that is so loud and
cumbersome and has no special skills
whatsoever ago I mean aside from being
hilarious but I'm talking about like in
a superpower game I have your childhood
Batman who's yours Michael Keaton mine's
Val Kilmer is wielding one small fresh
salad for everyone in the world okay
this person is great wait what they're
wielding one small fresh salad for
everyone in the world
I mean wielding that's a lot of salad
yeah where does he keep it you just
can't you like Santa but with salad and
escape yeah okay that's great I mean I
love Brittany but goddamn I really want
Batman to give me a salad more than I
want to hear Hydra and honestly she
might survive this that whatever
disaster we're all going through if it
turns into a winter apocalypse you can
ski around and we'll all be walking like
idiots shoo and we won't even hear her
hydro class dropping because it's gonna
be dropping on snow damn okay let's go
with that man though yeah we have to
sorry Brittany is there one more you
pull it
should we just decide to keep him or no
okay okay how do we end up with an odd
number I don't know an Instagram baddie
with nowhere to go who has scissor hands
and doesn't know how to control them
this just seems like Oh No
all sorts of problems Oh No an Instagram
baddie with nowhere to go and also has
Scissorhands oh no we're considering
that they're going against no opponent I
think they still lose
terrible terrible just a nuisance just
the worst just a liability dangerous
confusing no it's just not good Oh No
Brittany broski on skis later okay so
now we go to the semifinals right yep
what what how do we end up with oh I
guess okay all right you want to go from
top to bottom
sure okay so we have your childhood
Batman wielding a small fresh salad for
everyone in the world versus Nic Cage in
an actual cage with an army of rats that
have small football helmets on fresh
salad though for everybody who wants
salad oh I like salad okay I don't
so you're saying Nic Cage an actual case
could be a small army of rat I just
personally don't see the limit to what
that is capable of mmm like well you
know he's only got one and after that
he's done one for everyone so everybody
Cage can command his army to be like
okay go get some more food every single
day and the rats will come back with
food with helmets on - with helmets on
they're tough rats yeah and think about
this I mean if you're considering the
fact that the rats might not be
motivated to work think about how scared
they are of a giant Nic Cage sighs Nic
Cage in a cage they can also play
football so they're entertaining there
when they're running plays and they're
coordinated yeah you're right I mean
after he gives everybody their one salad
he's really he's hold on okay it's
Batman yeah so salads aside we have a
superhero true but we're all gonna be
resenting him that he can't feed us the
whole time because he feeds us a salad
and we're like
hungry and he only works in Gotham yeah
what the heck like either either Freddy
franchise your business or get out of
here yeah dude come on give us a couple
more Batman's okay
Nick Cage wins so then does he go up
against the winner or do the winners
just keep going okay
Home Depot as a person who knows what
scenario 51 we have to tickle them too
I'm gonna tell you the intense vocals
only of Celine Dion and her native
languages Fred she has great French
albums you fake fans I can heal people
with peeing on them is interesting so
now we have the power of urine and
French vocals versus Home Depot as a
person I feel like Home Depot as a
person should win because even if they
know what's inside area 51 you have to
tickle them they still have all the
supplies and knowledge inside of a Home
Depot which is helpful whereas Celine
Dion's vocals have to pee on you yeah
and think about this like yeah you're
helping us and you're healing us but
yeah it smells like pee all the time yes
we don't know if it actually works yeah
and you know what another thing he
doesn't just happen okay you need to
consume water and she's stealing all the
goddamn water
I'm sorry Celine's vocals you're nice to
listen to but you got to get out
take him out get him out of here the
entire cast of Jersey Shore in a hot tub
that moves writing a John Deere tractor
backwards but can do gainers versus Dog
the Bounty Hunter and he's all out of
bounties with toilet paper guns fans mm
I'm sorry I'm biased but the Jersey
Shore cast and a hot tub doing gainer I
feel like could be a destructive force a
huge destructive force it's basically a
tank yeah and what what they can't
physically destroy they can't
emotionally in verbally destroy and wear
down easily I'm gonna go with Jersey
Shore on a John Deere st. hot tub saying
later Dog the Bounty Hunter sorry dog
okay speedo man spider-man's caffeine
addicted cousin with the fus-ro-dah
one loud fus-ro-dah you only got one
though or a doctor with Girl Scout
cookies
so does speed him in at have like web
mobility and like can he like swing
around
no he's just addicted to caffeine yeah
is he wear an outfit or is he is the guy
know he just shows all its speed oh man
I hate him mm-hmm
he's just got one loud shell because
he's all hopped up on caffeine he'll
probably do it in the wrong direction
and help nobody okay Speedman
get out your husband's way cooler than
you and then Adam Sandler who knows how
to do LASIK as the cobbler I mean I kind
of just want him to be gone because I
will not be choosing him as my hero I
just won't
oh yeah no all right all right so we
have the final four we have a home depot
as a person Nic Cage in a cage Jersey
Shore and a hot tub that moves or a
doctor I'm sorry but I already know the
winner is it Jersey Shore no hots of
that movie yeah riding a John Deere
tractor backwards but can-do gainer yeah
what's a gainer can you explain it for
people who might not know so in diving
it's called a reverse but it's when your
body is moving forward but you're
flipping backwards so if you're facing
forward and you jump off of something
you then flip backwards
that's a gainer you've probably seen
videos of people doing it but it's a
John Deere tractor doesn't typically do
gainers let alone one that has an a hot
tub that moves on it with the entire
cast of Jersey Shore because also if
they can successfully pull this move off
which they can they've broken the laws
of physics because the water in the hot
tub isn't leaving no it's not though it
stays in there and it stays hot it stays
hot it's not plugged into anything not a
water source not a heat source no not an
electrical not at all
there is many large bodies fit but also
large yes it again get in tan getting
heated constantly it's a constant source
of heat and energy mm-hmm they're
breaking laws of physics with the water
not spilling out with a tractor being
able to do a gainer with an entire tub
of water full of Jersey Shore cast
members in a destructive force to be
reckon there's so much to to unpack from
this
I just feel like it's an endless source
of support and help and then a comment
light and love and light and if we're
all if anytime we get bored mm-hmm
we don't even need a TV we just watch
them cuz you know I mean they're gonna
be entertaining probably to Home Depot
you're out Nic Cage or you can stay for
a sec doctor I don't want your cookies
you're a bad doctor you shouldn't be
eating on the jobs right you shouldn't
be eating on the job tell them your
profession if you're an actual doctor in
this situation you don't get to be a guy
you're a doctor you put in your mouth on
your hand yeah and he eats the cookies
with his fingers like that and he always
eats the worst one what's the worst kind
I don't know but I like that one but
caramel whatever he's eating it's not
thin mints
okay Thin Mints are the best caramel
delight sorry so the opinion in a
head-to-head match with an army of rats
with football helmets on even come close
to this Jersey Shore just phenomenon
flying doing Gators no they have energy
sources like to power the John Deere
John beer gas in it maybe it's electric
and it's solar-powered otherwise it
cannot continuously do gainers with a
hot tub on it just can't nothing can do
that it's so much energy output do we
know why they're doing gainers to avoid
bumps in the road yeah no that's I'm
sorry but there is no argument for a
Nick Cage in a cage with a small army of
rats wearing football helmets yeah I do
think there would be a really good
superhero movie about that guy though
mm-hmm he's like like you said sort of
the Rat King but he's also just kind of
a rat lives underground
okay well 580 little piece of [ __ ] boy
he commands a giant army of rats with
football helmets on
who are coordinated they run NFL quality
level plays together to go get food and
go get that cheese dog and Nick Cage in
a cage has like sharp teeth but they
didn't get him out of the cage so he
that's where he lives he likes it there
it's his throne okay
no Jersey Shore in a hot tub
riding a John Deere tractor that can
only go backwards but can do Gators
alright Jersey sure on a hot tub that
moves the winners they are the heroes we
need right now the heroes we need good
stuff great stuff this is this is what I
call contributing to society what we've
done here today because we've plotted
out the most important people that could
that could ever lead Society in time of
need which is now and so you know what
next time you're going you know looking
out your window or you know reading
about things on the news just keep in
mind that you might see a very fast John
Deere doing gainers backwards driving
that wait how do you wait hold on if
they're going backwards then it's a
front flip yeah it's a front gainer how
do they know where they're going do they
just crash in the stuff all the time
they don't know who's driving Ouiser guy
driving it's autopilot okay that's it
that's that's it that's the winner
mm-hmm amazing I feel good about what we
did today here same feeding backwards
doing it's all [ __ ] just screaming at
each other using a Doppler effect is
like loudly loudly loudly quietly like
the noise changes Wow incredible they're
not getting paid either so they're
pissed they're pissed but they're warm
and it might be called out depends where
it goes it's it's a natural phenomenon
why there why that hot tub is still hot
years and years later its traversed
around the globe they're not hungry
like it's just a self-sufficient like
spectacle they're trapped in time yeah
mm-hmm Wow it's like seeing Bigfoot yeah
it is like seeing Bigfoot just louder
and more jersey and more destructive
than tanner yeah you know what what I
love being a part of something bigger
than myself which was that's what today
was about yeah fish a physically a John
Deere tractor with a hot tub on top of
it is massive and it's bigger than me
yeah and you it's amazing that attractor
can do a gainer with a hot tub on top of
it at all should we Google John Deere
Gator
because if if someone who has a John
Deere has ever done some sort of
acrobatic movement it is a hundred
percent of gainer
there's no way tractor gainer no no no
all right well uh get on it you know get
on it get working on the gainers twelve
tired giant twelve tired green cart
tractor what if it's like one of these
huge ones like a oh my god well wheels
but there's a hot tub on top of it and
it does a game it well maybe you know
what maybe they just they're like in a
bubble of anti-gravity maybe and then
they just well that's a big-ass John
Deere what does he spit now Wow very
cool stuff like one of those not like a
little tractor also wouldn't work
anyways I mean I feel good about I feel
bad about what we did here Carm you need
a hug hopefully uh you guys enjoyed our
very serious game that we played today
incredibly serious that um we now know
our new heroes so
these are the heroes we need and
hopefully everyone is well and staying
safe and not losing their mind and we'll
be back for another podcast next week
and we'll be live on Twitch all week but
thank you guys for hanging there
listening and joining along we
appreciate you and we we're thinking of
all of you so be good and we'll see you
guys at week
[Music]